police in Italy are investigating a grim
discovery that may be tied to a
decades-old mystery human remains were
found at a building next to the Vatican
Embassy in Rome some Italians believe
the bones belonged to a teenage girl who
vanished in the 1980s Seth Doane is in
for mangina Italy Seth good morning good
morning those human bones were found
during a renovation project at the
Vatican's Embassy to Italy in a
residential section of Rome the Vatican
immediately called Italian authorities
to investigate those bones were found in
a building that was apparently attached
to the embassy now it is not yet known
how old those bones are whether those
bones belong to more than one poor
person or the gender of the deceased
however Italian media is speculating
that they could be the remains of a
Manuela Orlandi the fifteen-year-old
daughter of a Vatican employee who
vanished in 1983 or Ilan DS
disappearance is a case that has
captivated attention here in Italy and
has spawned many conspiracy theories of
sex rings some suggesting Vatican
involvement and what is thought to be
her murder others have pointed at the
Mafia at one point a tomb was opened to
try to solve the case but in 35 years it
has remained one of the great unsolved
mysteries here in Italy and now the
director of the Holy See press office
Greg Burke has said he has urged caution
he said this will likely take time first
a period of death must be established
and Johnny says that will not take a few
days but could take more time